hello sir oh hi it's Gordon Freeman's on
the side Peter brand hey hey he spoke
words dance has been pretty good boy
danton Peter brands you were not the
individual who reviewed danky kang no
ma'am what's the official title a cocky
kong country tropical freeze danky kang
country yes tropical freeze pretty much
you've got a weird accent I don't know
what that it's just the way I was raised
you know a donkey kong country tropical
freeze I wasn't sure when I moved over
here I'm sure it's just like a European
pronunciation of danky kang yeah danky
kang yeah thank you can yeah and mark
walton in our UK office obviously
reviewed the game yeah yeah but you
played a bunch of it as well I played a
little bit yeah and I quite enjoy it i'm
a fan of the old games and this is a you
know it takes a lot of stuff that made
those great and that made donkey kong
country returns on the weed great and
just runs with it you know a lot more of
it all right let's hop straight into it
we got it right here let's do it comes
coming up man maybe I better hang it up
just to tell you get out of an airplane
yes I like to open I lost the tip just
the tip of the aircraft fell off how
unfortunate we've done out of their guts
donkey and old man [ __ ] what's old man
kann called again cranky okay sorry
cranky Kang uh yeah so give us a skivvy
on this uh this is a side-scrolling
action platformer I mean it's it's very
much what the donkey kong series is
traditionally known for doggy gone
country I don't count country series
sorry yeah very different from
traditional donkey kong of course um you
know mark walton found that this game
had a few issues hmm I i I'm not gonna
you know dispute you know his opinion
but he's full of crap well better better
you than me Chris no no no I mean you
know not everyone likes games for the
same reasons I like this game because it
is it it sticks to what it does best
which is sort of traditional platforming
and you know what I really like what it
does the level design is great although
I can't really hear it right now the
soundtrack is done by david wise okay
the gentleman who did a lot of work for
rare back in the day is that guys who
made the first Donkey Kong Country
Series games and yeah and he's back and
he's just one of the best video game
music composers out there by far and I
got a question here from twitter from
rob rough
yo who asks would you consider the new
donkey kong country is a must have for
the wii u 4 yes if I own a wii u this is
a game that I would buy I don't own oh
but you're what's wrong with the video
game price what that I don't get paid
enough more like in the way yes yes uh
no I think this game is fantastic it's
it's amazing with two people nah you
know playing and that's really where I
think it's enjoyed best can you drop in
with a second person anytime uh I don't
believe so you actually have to back out
of the menu and choose two players yeah
that was a choice when I was setting
this up before the show to choose single
player or yeah two player now I mean
right now this is the very start of the
game so it's introducing a lot of the
rules to me you know yes that's
different mechanics monkeys can swim
monkeys can in fact swim and fish around
like monkeys yes your dicks Oh hate them
but uh so as you progress through the
game gets much more difficult and the
the environments are you know more
hazardous and well hello turtle just got
me so I should please don't worry you
have plenty of my balloons you up from
the underworld as in real life balloons
equal resurrection I knew I should have
gotten the budget to get mark Walton
flown over to play with Peter brand you
disappoint me again well we got a
question from a on the score holidays
yes I'm it's my favorite part of the
show by the way i just read net people's
dumb names what's the best character to
play eyes in danky kang it's real name
hope this i'm so sorry that's a real
name or a beautiful like an Arthur in
fairness the guy called ode Dwyer was
the person who said is it a hell of his
uh like Cynthia's friend is it sorry
Cynthia we've all met that guy um so I'd
say it for Danny it's a four day nikkah
yeah I'd say either diddy kong or dixie
kong he can watch me right now I've got
diddy kong on my back and he gives you a
little bit of hang time it is diddy kang
yeah didn't king oh this right yeah
sorry chris is accents rubbing off
cranky Kong has a
there we go well he's got like a little
bit of a cane that lets him bounce on
spikes and other hazards you know freely
our emerged McDuck style is either yeah
beat up young punk apes yeah back in my
day teacher except you have to start
with him you have to finish the level by
4pm because it so that metal thing
rising from the background right there
that large tree those are the sort of
effects that give this game a lot of
personality and uh and charm and you
know it's yes the gameplay is rather
traditional but the set dressings are
really great I think I always find a way
that like these games kind of pull off
the we're just basically doing what we
did in the past but it looks better in a
way that like the sonic games have never
been able to achieve I think that might
be because these games embrace what
worked and don't try to innovate just
for the sake of innovation right sonic
for whatever reason Sega's decided to
you know put into all these different
you know roles and give them a lot of
different tools to use and they just
don't work as well as the simple formula
that frankly works so well in the path
of trying to make him a Mario they
should have made him a donkey kong uh
well I should have kept him side well
yep using the Nintendo better foyer
Maggie gonna stick with me I get what
you mean it's yeah but I I don't know
the donkey that this is not the first
that wasn't our DK game that came out
last year as well ya don't mind then she
turns on the wii and then it was ported
to the 3d yes right I didn't play that
version but I did play the wii version
it had some you know like obligatory
motion controls that weren't necessary
because there was a button that went
unused yeah but you know the level
design was great the music although not
by david wise i believe was still again
really good are there much fundamental
differences between this game and
kentucky cranky kong and dixie kong the
the girl sorry cranky canyon Dixie King
the Guru hey thank you oh there there
are new additions and uh yeah you know I
mean that's that's pretty much it so did
he does the jetpack thing does Dixie do
the hair yes alterra copter yeah I mean
her and and did he are you know exactly
like they were in the past and cranky
Kong is sort of the only real
new character to the series as playable
I've got a question here it's here I'm
from they the name pod day apod deja
losa which I just want to make a special
effort to say he's a really wonderful
beautiful name and what does dixie kong
do she is asked to be a twitch yeah so
she can jump and like Diddy she can
hover by spinning her hair around in a
copter like motion hmm just like really
want to make a willow smith joke now but
I feel like that's not pertinent highway
not yeah not with it yeah hey kids
underscore you may on Twitter fantastic
name your parents great choice and do
you think danky kang will rival the
mario game when it comes to multiplayer
gameplay mmm local co-op well it's mario
3d world world are we talking about yeah
so that's a 4 player you know full 3d
Mario game that is a lot of fun to play
it's it's a different type of co-op
experience I think that's more about the
cooperation aspect or even the trolling
aspect yeah of different players this is
this game punishes you pretty heavily
for miss steps so this is this is solely
focused on cooperative play trolling has
no place here and isn't actually that
easy to do this is more of a traditional
co-op you are just along for the ride
yes yeah yeah choice Mario is very much
a playground for you know in a lot of
respects at peter brian i'm gonna ask
you some questions about the nintendo
wii u we have a bunch of conversations
in the office but that's a lot let's do
it at DK here sorry dying which stands
for danke of course and is a biggest
release of 2014 for the wii u so far
we've got bayonetta coming I've been
there too or other yeah super mario 3d
world as well oh is that actually a
discount here oh that was november yes I
that was november and what how do you
think games like this are going to
impact on the the sales of the wii u
which is obviously suffering a lot of
them yeah so for me personally this is
one of the biggest game the most
interesting games coming out this year I
don't know that this is going to be the
sort of thing that's going to sell
people on the wii
you you know again I think everyone has
their favorite series and maybe there's
some people really love donkey kong
country and will pick up a Wii U for it
yeah I'm considering it actually and you
know I've wanted one for a while but
this is actually the first game that's
gotten me like just seriously consider
what I'm missing I've played a bunch of
in the office but I've not been able to
take it home and really player out with
it that said I think it's going to be
the tail end of 2014 maybe 2015 when
games such as monoliths softs big RPG x
mmm comes out that's really going to tip
a lot of people off to what the Wii U
has to offer which you know the hardware
is its powerful ish compared you know
compared to ps4 and Xbox well I'm not
unpowered no but but the the software is
where it needs to succeed I know a lot
of people talk about the you know this
I'd concept of the killer app keeps
getting thrown around yeah you know
we--you it seems more like what they're
going to have is a library of oh yeah
full of games that people eventually
almost like you're Chinese water torture
style you just eventually they're gonna
wear you down yeah Chris what do you
think about it well I think we sort of
talked about this a little bit with the
xbox one and the ps4 is that you know
with the advent of titanfall is that
going to be the thing that shifts the
needle for the xbox one bringing it more
in line with ps4 sales I think that
looking ahead this year it's gonna be
the multiplayer titles that are really
gonna get get people to be like oh like
my friend has this game I want to be
able to play it at my want to have my
friends over and play mario kart yeah
smash brothers it's not a bit of course
they're broken up I think though you
know you know compared to donkey kong
country tropical freeze this like be
careful dress is lovely and it looks
great and it's a lot of fun but but that
like multiplayer aspect I think in terms
of not only interminably helping like
you evangelize like come over my house
like maybe we're gonna play this game
but if we have mario kart or smash
brothers we're definitely gonna play
that you know and multiple that you can
play that you can like to have a bunch
of people over to play it so I think
that it's just gonna like well it has a
potential to exponentially multiply the
amount of people that are getting their
hands off you yeah us and that's always
the most powerful you know the elevator
is like when you actually play it and
actually have fun
you make good wii sports was one of
those games where we needed people
invited in tonight so that's how I kind
of spread like almost like a virus where
like people were playing in their friend
says then they got one they're like oh
you gotta come over and play this thing
you know I can't believe I forgot about
Mario Kart and smash brothers yeah those
are two really important games actually
i'd say maybe those more than this or
maybe just the trio my tip to scale for
a lot of people who are that's certainly
the trio of like nintendo stuff but i
think you're right Peter I mean you
mentioned Bayonetta and that X game for
monoliths off that's cute those games
have it they're more of like the cult
hit könig is that like really have a
chance to sort of you know take off and
be part of the conversation online like
those of the games would come back
people come back to gamespot like over
and over years and years ago yeah and
joining forums and talking about it like
it's it's those deep games those games
that are unique that really sort of can
catch on the people so I feel like a
Nintendo Moines anything at the moment
needs to shed themselves of the if not
the reliance to proceed to reliance on
their stalwarts they're like traditional
Mario's and danky kang xand one cos they
just need to branch out a bit i mean
they've done you know they didn't they
were able to do it a little bit on the
wii but not strong enough I think the
Wii U with the titles you guys just
talked about will help them quite a bit
awesome peter brian thank you very much
for coming on and showing us and what's
this game called again danky kang
country returns tropical fruit fantastic
yeah so if you're if you're doing
jeopardy at any stage in the future and
a question comes up do they know what to
write